quand patrick mbuyu bakambu chercheur en
droit public à l'université paris saclay
bonjour bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous jean louis borloo s'est donc étonné
hier je vais le site et comment un
dispositif voté à l'unanimité des
sénateurs voté à l'unanimité des députés
saluée par les mamans des quartiers des
par les mamans des quartiers les jeunes
les femmes les maires les présidents
d'agglomération par 100 % des organismes
hlm comment cette décision de la nation
française at elle pu s'arrêter sans que
personne ne l'ait jamais décidé alors
comment vous qui êtes chercheur en droit
public expliquez nous comment est ce que
on peut en arriver là l'explication doit
être recherchée justement dans ce
travail parlementaire dans quête d'
analyse pour citer jean louis borloo et
jean louis borloo puisque c'est assez
étonnant de constater que ce travail qui
avait mobilisé pas mal d'acteurs locaux
d'élus et des parlementaires puissent
aujourd'hui se retrouver inactif puisque
il ne parle pas d'un rapport qui a été
annulée personne n'a jamais pris la
décision d'annuler mais simplement il
faut revenir au discours d' emmanuel
macron en main 2018
quand il avait carrément j'étais aux
oubliettes le rapport en disant que deux
hommes blancs vont ces avancées vont
présenter un rapport concernant des
quartiers qui n'habitent pas un discours
m un petit peu caricaturale dans ce sens
et cela avait déjà retiré à son plan son
dynamisme puisque en réalité puisque le
président est en train de décliner ce
rapport publiquement devant le monde
entier
pourquoi un fonctionnaire de bercy ou
encore de la direction générale des
collectivités territoriales ou encore de
l'agencé nationale de la rénovation
urbaine va se donner la peine à pouvoir
appliquer un accord décrié publiquement
par le président de la république c'est
là que se trouve le problème
or le sénat là où a été entendu mais
jean louis borloo a justement cette
mission qui lui a été dévolue par la
constitution d' évaluer les politiques
publiques et lui il est revenu au sénat
en tant que représentant de
des collectivités territoriales selon
l'article 24 de la constitution pour
pouvoir leur poser la question comment
se fait-il qu'un document que vous vous
avez approuvé dans votre mission de
représenter les collectivités
territoriales se retrouve aujourd'hui
non appliquées pas réduit à 30 40 % mais
complètement non appliquée c'est là que
se trouve le problème et c'est le
travail parlementaire qui va permettre
de répondre à cette question c'est donc
pour ça que jean louis borloo demande
aujourd'hui une enquête parlementaire
qu'est ce que ça va pouvoir apporter
finalement politiquement lui-même ne
souhaite pas de s'asseoir une sorte
d'inquisition contre le gouvernement en
place puisque ce serait plutôt malvenu
mais je pense que ça fait partie de la
mission du sénat aux nues par les monts
en général de pouvoir évaluer ce rapport
qui n'a jamais été annulée
concrètement mais pour qu'on puisse
savoir où est ce qu'auront à quel niveau
on en est par rapport à l'application de
ce texte puisque ça ne relève pas
seulement de cet acte sa relève aussi de
la crédibilité de l'action publique
demain nous allons avoir des difficultés
à pouvoir appliquer des politiques
notamment dans le cadre des mesures
adoptées pour les collectivités rurales
vous savez cette politique de la ville
dans le cadre dans lequel s'inscrira
jean jean louis borloo c'est dans
l'organisation générale des territoires
or emmanuel macron il son gouvernement
ont du mal à gérer les territoires c'est
ainsi connaît des problèmes de gilet
jaune et aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec
ce rapport sur les quartiers qui étaient
complètement gta aux oubliettes alors on
va revenir assez rapidement sur la
situation dans les quartiers populaires
mais avant ça cib et n'diaye la porte
parole du gouvernement a répondu tout à
l'heure à jean louis borloo
une mission parlementaire est déjà à
l'oeuvre on va avoir des dizaines de
milliers de logements rénovés
reconstruit d'équipements publics
construits les crédits de l'indre ont
été multipliées par deux c'est donc ce
qu'a expliqué cib et n'diaye ou dans les
eaux alors cette politique de la ville
et de la situation dans les quartiers
populaires la situation n'a pas
tellement évolué puisque la politique de
la ville est aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle
est et ce clip quand le rapport a été
rédigé en il ya toujours des difficultés
deux fois moins des lycéens dans les
filières générales transforme en
équipements sportifs
il ya encore des fois plus des ménages
sans voiture et même des quartiers plus
de 160 quartiers prioritaires quand on
récence qui n'ont même pas des moyens
d'accès direct aux transports ça n'est
pas de bus pas de tram pas de métro
erreurs on n'en parle même pas donc ce
sont des situations qu'il convient de
pouvoir étudier puisqu'il faut pas
simplement parler des hlm qu'on va
rénover ou encore des rues qu'on va
réhabiliter ou encore des maisons des
quartiers qu'on va rouvrir mais plutôt
de l'avis des gens qui vivent puisque ce
sont quand même des français c'est la
même problématique qui a aussi posé
problème la même démarche qui a été un
petit peu difficile à appréhender
quand il s'est agit de répondre à la
crise du gilet jaune comment on aborde
la question des paies des territoires
périphériques périurbain et des
territoires ruraux
la même problématique se pose
aujourd'hui pour les quartiers au sein
des villes c'est difficile à appréhender
mais il faut laisser des gens qui savent
le faire faire ce travail encore une
toute dernière question comment est-ce
que vous expliquer qu'on ait tant de mal
à mettre en place une politique de la
ville qui soient pérennes le plan de
borloo alors il a été le plan de jean
louis borloo a été retoquée en 2018 mais
ce n'était pas le premier du genre y en
a eu des tas soit c'est sous les
différents mandats présidentiels et
malgré tout la situation dans les
quartiers populaires style exactement
malheureusement on en est arrivé à des
situations telles que l'effondrement des
deux immeubles qu'on a connu à marseille
l'année dernière notamment qui a posé
des problèmes n'ont glané il ya deux ans
par don qui a posé des difficultés
terribles qui a révélé les difficultés
terribles dans l'application de la
politique de la ville
il faut savoir simplifier les choses il
ya tellement des strates
il ya tellement des niveaux surtout à
l'est dont plan territorial que la prise
des décisions pour changer les choses
la vie des gens concrètement est
difficile à prendre et surtout à mettre
en oeuvre il faut fluidifier c'est pour
cela ce rapport avec l'intérêt de
pouvoir mettre proposé 19 programmes
avec des chefs de file et les personnes
qui vont les conduire mais de manière à
ce que ça pis on puisse avoir du
répondant vis-à-vis des institutions
bien ciblés c'est ça justement il faut
faciliter la collaboration mais surtout
la décision au niveau des instances et
réduire les strates de décision afin
qu'on puisse avoir une application
concrète et réelle sur l'amélioration de
la vie des gens merci beaucoup pour
votre un éclairage est africain boys au
bas-congo je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur en droit public à l'université
paris saclay je crois merci